allora non c'è dubbio che la storia
personale
vi dico subito non vi faccio arrivare
alla fine come un thriller sul perché le
storie hanno così successo
io preferisco il tenente colombo prima
sappiamo l'assassino e poi scopriamo
come si fa scoprire l'assassino
le storie sono così rilevanti perché
servono per sapere perché io sono maria
grasso e non un'altra cioè perché
ciascuno di noi è quello che è
perché è possibile riuscire a vivere
socialmente insieme e perché la nostra
specie è la specie che ha assunto la se
promessi a nel processo evolutivo quindi
le storie servono per dire la mia
identità per dire la mia società così
com'è e come è fatta e riconoscersi e
perché noi riusciamo a sopravvivere come
specie questo è l'assassino adesso provo
un pò a raccontarvi molto brevemente
come si arriva l'assassino non c'è ombra
di dubbio che quando noi già da piccoli
abbiamo i genitori che ci raccontano
storie ma appena riusciamo a proferire
qualche parola alle storie diciamo
ancora e diciamo e adoriamo da bambini
le storie che fanno un po terrore e un
po paura
in realtà se ci pensiamo
la cosa l'immagine che ci viene in mente
è quello di share asado delle mille e
una notte
lei grazie alle storie si salva la pelle
se non avesse non fosse stata capace a
raccontare storie sarebbe morta in
realtà vale anche per noi
cosa succede da bambini cosa succede il
fatto che fino alla fine della nostra
vita raccontiamo storie
possiamo leggerle possiamo vederle e
oggi le troviamo in rete o le sentiamo
raccontare qui che sono state fino
adesso storie tutte molto interessanti e
per noi molto istruttive io dovrei
parlare di come le neuroscienze
raccontano questo successo ci arrivo per
gradi
vi racconto in primo luogo una storia
una delle tante storie quando la francia
si divide in due e il generale peten
decide di accettare il governo di
governare a vichy in realtà viene
costruito un piccolo libricino questo
qui e molti così dice noi diremmo oggi
cartelloni pubblicitari che avevano
scritto c'era una volta dentro il libro
che cosa viene raccontato viene
raccontato che ci sono due bambini
piccoli che vedono un adulto il nonno
che piange ma perché piangi nonno e dice
la francia e sconfitta i bambini dicono
chiamiamo una fata chiamiamo i maghi e
chiamiamo mago silvestro e lui diceva
mago silvestro e imprigionato non lo non
è tempo di fate e di maghi dice ma io
sacrifico dono la mia persona alla
francia per aiutarla nelle sue disgrazie
la storia il raccontare storie è anche
un modo per plasmare la relazione con
gli altri
questo è uno dei tanti esempi
ma la storia è molto lunga questa
immagine qui che non mandiamo nel
filmato è molto interessante perché se
voi andate in rete la trovate scoprirete
che chiunque la vede questi due
triangoli e il cerchio incominciano ad
entrare in relazione e quanto si domanda
ma come che cosa è successo in quel
filmato quasi tutti si inventano delle
relazioni amorose e di conflitto fra i
due triangoli per ottenere il successo
con il cerchio in genere sappiamo che
simbolicamente i due triangoli sono
simboli maschili e il cerchio è un
simbolo femminile ma adesso comincio
provare a di a raccontarvi qualche cosa
sulle neuroscienze la forma più diffusa
di storia è il pettegolezzo viviamo di
pettegolezzi ma sai maria grazia è
andata alla ted conference
se lo dico così c'è già tutto un
implicito che è una storia e alla
domanda che veniva presentata dallo
speaker precedente perché perché è
andata la ted conference
devo incominciare a raccontare una
storia
il perché è una storia lo spiegarsi il
perché delle cose la sola risposta è già
una storia
ma la cosa interessante è che abbiamo
si è scoperto in termini di neuroscienze
che non c'è nessuna differenza nelle
relazioni sociali
addirittura si pensa che sia la stessa
origine dal grooming degli animali lo
spulciarsi l'inglese sappiamo benissimo
che braille grumi e lo sposo ride non
sappiamo anche che vuol dire il fatto
che comunque io cerco di ade scarti
nella terminologia rumen nei primati non
solo quelli anche nei gorilla serve a
definire le gerarchie quindi il grumi il
pettegolezzo è una gerarchia io col
pettegolezzo posso accreditare opposto
togliere la reputazione ad una persona
quindi è una validazione e una modalità
di gerarchia e noi siamo non solo
ascoltatori ma siamo anche produttori di
storie perché siamo sembrerebbe che
siamo produttori di storia perché la
storia ci toglie dal momento del
presente dal qui e ora
la storia il presente lo posso solo
raccontare dopo e quindi il premi toglie
dallo spazio e mi toglie dal tempo e da
senso la frammentazione di tanti
presenti costruisce il senso di quello
che faccio e di quello che sono e questo
senso mette insieme sembra core
costruire il fluire della dinamica del
tempo il primo soggetto che racconta la
storia è il nostro corpo perché il
nostro corpo dice come ha interagito nel
tempo con l'ambiente e ha interagito nel
tempo con l'ambiente all'esterno e con
il nostro ambiente interno se noi siamo
persone che sono cresciute in una storia
emotiva fortemente rigida magari
fortemente astiosa non c'è ombra di
dubbio che i tratti somatici del nostro
volto e delle nostre dinamiche
espressive
lo raccontano e quindi il primo testo
che racconta la storia di chi siamo
ancora prima di aprire la bocca è il
nostro corpo ma
siamo in realtà con le storie non solo
fuori dal nostro tempo è fuori dal
nostro spazio
siamo anche alla ricerca della
possibilità di vivere altre vite
non solo la mia e nel momento in cui
sento un altra vita immediatamente la
confronto con la mia la natura il
processo biologico ha prodotto negli
esseri umani una cosa che ormai
moltissimi conoscono è una ricerca tutta
italiana fatta all'università di parma
di cui poi negli stati uniti in giappone
si sono fatte tante ricerche analoghe
che la parolina magica che oggi molto
utilizzata ma bisogna stare anche tanto
attenti utilizzarla che la modalità
empatica il sistema mirror scoperto
all'università di parma ci consente di
capire che cosa succede dentro il nostro
cervello e dentro il nostro corpo quando
sentiamo una storia su una persona ci
racconta una storia noi è come seri
producessimo nel nostro corpo
comprendendo il linguaggio e vedendo i
movimenti esattamente che cosa ha fatto
un'altra persona per cui le storie ci
fanno davvero non solo idealmente
concretamente vivere oltre alla nostra
vita la vita degli altri e la vita degli
altri entra
tramite il sistema neurale nella nostra
stessa vita per cui noi siamo noi perché
siamo anche tutto l'insieme delle
relazioni che abbiamo avuto con altri è
l'elemento centrale lo vedremo assai
successiva di questa dinamica è la
dimensione emotiva
le storie sono affascinanti pensate al
modello del fascino di un sentimento
come l'amore dove il modello per noi
occidentali e giulietta e romeo e se
pensiamo alla nostra cultura
il modello dell'inganno è cappuccetto
rosso per cui l'apprendimento e un
apprendimento del del tentativo di
capire come imparare a comportarci
socialmente di fronte ad alcune cose che
dobbiamo affrontare questo ormai spiega
molto bene perché i bambini chiedono non
una ma cento volte di vedere lo stesso
cartone e cento volte la stessa identica
storia perché hanno b abbiamo bisogno di
imparare tutti i particolari perché così
in quella situazione
impariamo quali sono i rischi le difese
i premi e le sanzioni c'è un esperimento
uno dei tanti esperimenti notate che
sulla narrazione oggi si sta investendo
molto in termini di ricerche di
neuroscienze moltissime quantità di
soldi sono investiti in quella direzione
proprio per il loro fascino per la loro
presa e per il ruolo educativo sociale e
dell'identità c'è un interessante
esperimento oltretutto fatto da un euro
economista il quale ha provato a mettere
di fronte allo schermo una storia
drammatica e si è scoperto che nel
momento in cui aumentava il grado di
drammatizzazione nel corpo di tutti
coloro che partecipavano all'esperimento
avvenivano 2 impennate di due
particolari tipi di ormoni
il primo è lo so ti cina
quello che ci serve per metterci nei
panni degli altri
la modalità per la quale che ci consente
di incominciare a pensare che io posso
essere mi metto dal suo lato dal suo
punto di vista e l'altro in realtà è
stato il cortisolo che è
l'ormone dello stress dell'ansia ma
anche del grado di attenzione per cui
man mano che la condizione emotiva sale
il nostro grado di attenzione e cresce
questa insieme di elementi legati alla
possibilità di rispecchiarsi negli altri
alla possibilità di essere un soggetto
che ha fatto della sua storia che è
fatta di tutte le storie di tutti i
pettegolezzi che ha sentito nell'arco
della sua vita produce il fatto che noi
possiamo immaginare e immaginiamo per
simboli
penso al primo speaker di oggi che ha
disegnato era una storia ed era una
storia fatta di simboli
ecco sembrerebbe che proprio questa
capacità legata alla narrazione è quello
che ha fatto sì che l'uomo sapiens
sapiens predominante rispetto ad altri
tipi di ominidi che coi quali è comunque
ha convissuto e che consente noi oggi di
dire che siamo dei soggetti produttori
di cultura ma credo penso ritengo che il
successo della storia nasca dal fatto
che nessuna storia esterna
nessuna storia che raccontiamo a noi
stessi sia in grado di spiegare con le
parole la complessità vera dei nostri
vissuti e quindi c'è spazio per
tantissime altre storie tutte una
diversa dall'altra tanto quanto siamo
diversi ciascuno di noi uno dall'altro